invidious new 20 series has finally been
revealed and the 10 series is continuing
to drop in price so which is these
series are due by welcome to parties
hobbies
so finally we know all of our options
and the prices that go along with them
there are still a couple of twenty
series cards yet to come out but for the
most part the pros and cons for each
series remain the same neither one is
necessarily a better buy and it really
is just what fits your budget and needs
starting off with the cons of the twenty
series there is definitely a price
premium and an early adopters fee
associated with them at least for the
higher level cards so don't be surprised
if these prices drop in about a year or
so and at this point know that you'd be
paying more than most people not be able
to get earlier also the price for the
twenty series is already super high the
r-tx twenty eighty comes in at eight
hundred dollars the GTX 280 longs for
$700 so that right there is already a
one dollar premium this same story also
applies with the 2070 and 2080 ti as
well something else to consider is that
not all games will have support for
ray-tracing technology it will take some
time for them to adapt as new technology
and some games may never adapt actually
as a result even though you have to pay
upfront for this feature you may not
actually use it for quite a while and
finally real-time rate racing is one of
the biggest selling points of the RT x
20 series and we think about it it
really just is shadows details so it is
by no means a game changer to be
furthered by a 20 Series card make sure
to consider if you actually want to use
rate racing technology next up the pros
of the twenty series if you buy a 20
series card you'll be getting the latest
hardware available you will be getting
deterring architecture the neutral
animator process digital rec six memory
and many many more things and really
with any of these Arctic's cards you'll
have the best performance in the market
you'll have the top chord line premium
game experience and this will not be
beaten for quite a while and this next
thing may not be a big deal to you but
you
it does a real-time ray tracing and
clearly India has spent a long time
researching and developing these new
technology and that is why they spend so
much time covering it in their keynote
so that will definitely be a nice
feature to have and improve game
immersion as well and pretty much the
same story can be said about all the
twenty series cards it definitely is a
luxury item you don't need it to have a
great gaming experience but how do you
get it makes it even better but it does
come in at a premium price
moving on to attend series here are some
cons of it if you buy a 10 series GPU
right now you are buying outdated
technology it will definitely last you
quite a while for the future but it
still outdated technology and you could
have bought it quite a while ago and
pricing for some of these cards don't
seem to be going down and they are
really close to MSRP so it really
doesn't make sense to buy any of those
cards which are close to MSRP so far
Downer's lifetime but that's pretty much
all the cons for the 10 series and there
really are a lot of pros first of all
the price outstanding for many of the
cards actually especially for the GTX
many of these car tracking all-time lows
and right now you can actually get a GTX
1084 430 dollars and it won't be long
before it reaches the 300s so currently
you can get these cards for amazing
value and that is definitely not
something to take ranted also the top
level 10 series GPUs will pretty much
provide you with the same traditional
gaming experience as a 20 series - ray
tracing technology so if you don't care
about ray tracing and the shadows and
details and stuff then 10 series may be
a great option for you also while it is
outdated it will last you a very long
time to come especially to talk to your
cards like the 1070 1080 and 1080 TI and
finally the 10 series is well
established so you won't have any issues
with any games of programs and you may
run into some issues in the 20 series
with like driver issues but you will
definitely not have that problem with
the 10 series and in the end they're
really both great options and one option
isn't really better than the other one
if you want the newest best tech
available and you're okay with the
premium price then go with the 20 series
you know you won't be satisfied
without it however if you are looking
for the best value and you really just
care about the performance per dollar
you don't really care about those luxury
options like real-time rate racing then
attend suit is the best bet for you to
scout for a deal over the next couple of
weeks that's now a 10 series cart at the
perfect time but not just what I think
what do you guys think which series do
you think is more worth it and do you
think the 20 series actually a ripoff
make sure to comment down below what you
guys think because I do read all my
comments that I'm curious as to what you
guys think so make sure to post your
thoughts also if you guys like Samia
then make sure drop a like and consider
subscribing if you'd like to see more
videos just like this one but until then
I'm Hardy I'll see you guys on the next
one
[Music]